what's going on guys this is Rob and
before we start this video we lost a
member of the Rob port a couple days ago
John Hawks lost his dog of 13 years
which is always tough so you wanted me
to give him a shot oh I'm almost a
shoutouts really the ideal thing to do
here but I'm sorry for your loss John
it's always tough losing a dog believe
me I know it's pretty rough so if you
guys watching this in the comments
section leave John your well wishes you
know it's always tough losing a dog and
yeah thanks guys
okay so we are picking up with Wolverine
vol 1 well really Wolverine issue number
1 technically this is the seventh solo
series of Logan of James Howlett as
Wolverine god he's had a lot of solo
series over the year some of them have
been like miniseries right like the
original Wolverine solo series was a
miniseries then he had his actual
ongoing series but this is part of Dawn
of X and we knew it was only a matter of
time before Wolverine got one but what
this does is it initially picks up with
Wolverine basically having gone full on
old man Logan right having killed like
Domino and quit enquirer and Jean Grey
now here's the important thing to
understand here and this is why what
goes on right now a lot of you would
kind of look at this and be like oh man
here we go again like that's that's not
the point right like anybody who's been
following the x-men for any measure of
time would know that like it's
well-established at this point that any
mutant who dies can be brought back
right like that's kind of the cool thing
the idea of death now when it comes to
the x-men comics is this just a means to
further the story right to kind of
create mystery like who was it that did
this and different things like that we
know it was Wolverine here but I like
the idea of death not really being used
for shock factor for shock value but
being used as a means of like okay let's
see where this story goes right I
suppose one of these crazy things
because what we end up doing here is we
jump back to five days before and this
initially picks up with Wolverine
basically playing hide-and-seek with a
whole bunch of little kids and this is
cool this is one of the reasons why
Benjamin Percy is such a good comic book
writer he focuses on like these small
little nuanced details that make things
interesting and one of the big focal
points of Wolverine is kind of like this
inner turmoil that he's been going
through on one side he looks at krikawa
and he sees it as a bit of a problem in
the sense that people let their guard
down here and that when people let their
guard down people die hence the death of
Charles Xavier early on in the dawn of X
story and then of course his eventual
resurrection but the other struggle DS
going through is he kind of wants to let
his guard down
Wolverine sort of lived a life where for
the most part and really even ever since
ever since Sabretooth you know in the
idea that Sabretooth has killed his love
interest every every year on his
birthday it's the idea that he's always
been on his guard right he's always been
looking over his shoulder always
wondering who's coming for him next and
it's kind of nice to be in a place where
he doesn't really have to worry about
that right where he can essentially rest
easy and that's kind of a struggle that
he's been going through over the course
of the the series of Dawn of X now
because of the fact that he's hidden so
well if will reign warden does not want
to be found
he will not be found and the result is
that Jean
ends up basically saying okay you know
what the kids cutting or getting
frustrated though you know gene graze
like you want to him and they're like
yeah like give us a hint so she's like
okay and then she Yates will ran out of
the bush is we're just kind of this this
funny little thing but ultimately she's
told there's some money out of the docks
waiting for you of course it being Kitty
Pryde and the Marauders and so when
Wolverine gets down there that the two
of them kind of shara shara drink now
Kitty Pryde and Wolverine have a very
lengthy history for a for Kitty Pryde
and Wolverine it was almost kind of like
a surrogate father role right like or
like an older brother sort of role where
he saw her is somebody to look after
somebody to take care of that's why a
lot of the x-men viewed Kitty Pryde is
kind of like their child basically why
she's the child of the x-men because she
was very very young right she was in her
early teenage years when she first
joined the group and ultimately became
an adult as part of that group and so
that's why it's really not a big thing
for Kitty Pryde to kind of sit down with
Wolverine and say look it's obvious that
you're happy here right now it's obvious
this is a place that you enjoy being
relaxed enjoy the place that you're in
but again for Wolverine it's kind of
this continued to struggle and so the
question that Wolverine ultimately has
here is why have you brought me here and
what Kitty Pryde reveals is that while
the mutant population on krakoa does
control the flow of flowers coming from
kokoa right the flowers that basically
add years onto your life or they can
cure you from any illness things like
that while they control that insofar as
those countries that publicly support
aqua Cola end up having the drugs of
cajon bought publicly those countries
who cannot publicly support for Cola and
get their drugs through the black market
but Kurkova controls both sides it just
looks like the only control one side and
so because of that what Kitty Pryde is
notice is that over time the plants have
basically gone missing some of these
plants have basically vanished and that
seems to be sort of a natural
progression of things right it's like
the DEA and the drugs they they bust
people for overtime those drugs that
they that they take end up disappearing
little by little right whether they're
being used by DEA agents or being sold
by by the federal government whatever
the case is like it just kind of goes
missing it's just sort of the price of
doing business but what makes this more
intriguing is you've got a guy by the
name of Jeff banister and Jeff banister
is essentially a CIA agent at least that
looks to be the case who's investigating
all of this right talking to the FBI
working with him and the CIA is largely
been called in here because of the fact
that well it does have incident to take
place inside the United States which
would normally keep it to the purview of
the FBI that because of the fact that
Cocola is an extra
country right it's another country
outside the United States and these
drugs are coming from another country
outside the United States that it looks
like it's CIA if not DEA territory right
but at the end of the day the CIA being
involved here is really the question of
how far does this go
but essentially Jeff banister what he's
discovered here is that somebody has
essentially been getting their hands on
this pollen and then cooking it right
like literally turning it and turning it
into a kind of a drug lab and then using
it for whatever purpose they're using it
for
and that's when we switch over to one of
the more interesting aspects of the kind
of rise of the mutant population when we
pick up with what's called the order of
X and what we end up having here is
Wolverine truant and y'all talking to
sage remember sage and the reason why
she's in the position that she's in as
far as the the mutant population goes is
because sages mind works like a computer
everything she sees and everything that
her mind interprets is catalogued and
stationed away in stored away so long as
you never delete information out of like
your pictures folder on your computer
it'll stay there forever and that's the
way sages mind works and so where she
busily responds to Wolverine look I
can't really give you the exact
information that you're looking for when
he asks where these pedals going like
what's going on with this because she
likens it to the the number of cells the
human body loses every day what she
basically says is the only real
information I can give you is that Kirk
Owen flowers emanate a vast amount of
pollen with the various governmental
agencies out there this pollen is
monitored depending on what kind of
drugs people are making the air in
particular areas will become more dense
or something along those lines but by
whatever manner and whatever means the
atmosphere more or less is being
monitored by like multiple agencies out
there and so the results that she says
in this one particular location just
outside just outside of Moscow was this
huge amount of pollen that was basically
released right and because cocoa and
flowers carry and released so much
pollen that kind of points to the idea
that that's where it's taking place
right at the very least that's where
Wolverine needs to go and so that's when
we end up switching over to really what
makes Jeff banister kind of interesting
right because we could look at this and
we could kind of say okay so like
there's a CIA agent here and he's
helping track down the drugs who really
cares about this guy what makes this
cool is the direction that he's coming
from right he ends up having some
documents that are handed over to him by
by another member of the CIA and then of
course a doctor comes to visit him and
says your your daughter's ready to see
you now and that's when we get in there
and end up finding out the Jeff banister
is doing this from a place of anger and
the reason why is because he's talking
to his daughter and she's kind of like
you know what case are you working on
now that
all indications of that his daughter's
dying presumably of some kind of cancer
and he basically says like there are
flowers out there that that she knows
about Kirk Owen flowers that could heal
her but there are individuals out there
who were stealing them and then using
them to make drugs and that pisses him
off because instead of spreading those
flowers around and then letting you know
allowing people to heal instead they're
hoarding them for their own addiction
the result of this is that we end up
jumping over to the order of X and what
we end up finding out here is that in
the aftermath of a Xavier's broadcast to
the world right his telepathic broadcast
telling the world Ria's mutants are all
going to coalesce in krakoa we're all
going to go to this one location we're
all going to live here do not come and
bother us or we will destroy you that
kind of a thing that is kind of seen as
a rise of mutants right and so you know
it's almost like we're getting an
antithesis where previously it was the
idea of anti mean groups right the the
right organization or at least the the
right as they were called the Friends of
humanity when you look at these various
organizations that were out there a lot
of the human based groups wanted to see
the mutant population eradicated the
order of X sees the mutant population as
gods and wants to become God's like them
right so they're basically people who've
just kind of lost their way
and it's kind of a funny thing here
because witness happens quit inquire
comes to the realization that the order
of X worships them he immediately jumps
into it it's just like yeah man this is
legit he sees it as kind of a party
situation and so what we end up doing
here is is we pick up we'll release we
have quit inquire who just sort of like
jumps out into this crowd of people who
are celebrating the arrival of the x-men
kind of seen him as like yeah you know
they're they're great beings who are
here and his sort of sort of jumps into
the party only for it to turn out that
when they start popping these this this
pollen substance that they immediately
kind of start to go crazy right they
sort of begin losing their minds and
then they intend to like eat the mutants
right to consume their blood in order to
become gods just like you know any
anybody else now it's interesting to ask
the question would that work right like
would that work if they consumed the
blood of the mutant population with that
blood enter into their bloodstream and
then in turn allow them to become unions
probably not one because you're talking
about my blood types you know and
usually incorrect blood types do not mix
and Maki I could kill you too there's no
guarantee they could even handle those
powers in the first place and three it
doesn't really work that way so because
of that they're jumping in and trying to
fend off these various guys suddenly
they all start dropping dead and that's
when Jean Grey that's when Wolverine
that's what acquit enquirer come to the
realization that it's the Paul
that's essentially killing them again
tracking you know continuing on the
submission of tracking things down
Wolverine ends up coming into this place
outside of Moscow and tracking down
these Russian mob guys and then starts
asking questions and when Wolverine
doesn't notice that they have kind of
mutant power dampeners here at the end
of the day he pops the claws and makes
him talk and what they reveal is that
there's what's called the pale girl some
being out there with power that seems to
have the power of the purple man right
or maybe she's just kind of a telepath
whatever the case is she's referred to
as the pale girl and what she's done
here is she basically showed up on the
doorstep of these guys and said I will
give you the flowers of krikawa
but I'm gonna take 80% of the money that
you make right kind of setting up a drug
trade more or less and so when they
initially tried to defy the pale girl
went to sokovia and stole stole flowers
from there then ultimately the pale girl
showed up and then to make an example
out of them force the guy to essentially
burn his own eye out of his head again
we don't really know if it's like if
it's if it's telepathy but it would all
but also be interesting if it was the
powers of the purple man right if it was
somebody who had zebediah killgrave
abilities or something similar to those
and in turn could make people do things
but what we get is is kind of side by
side comparison right Wolverine coming
to this realization that somebody out
there is smuggling flowers out of kokoa
and then setting up a drug trade in the
process and then of course the Jeff
banister more or less comes to the same
conclusion and the question he has is
that one this can't really happen on the
books something like this is happening
because it's not really supposed to
right it's not something that could be
publicly done by the mutant population
and so this means that it's being sold
either as part of their black market or
there's somebody selling as a third
party and so what he proposes is to
basically go out there right go out
there is essentially drug dealers and
start tracking things down right start
tracking who this pale girl is and see
exactly how all this is working which
leads us back to wove reign at the
beginning of the story where basically
we end up realizing that somewhere along
the line in their investigations that
wolverine had tracked down the pale girl
and the pale girl had used her abilities
to force wolverine to kill the other
x-men and so when he kind of begins to
sort of give up right when he gets
frustrated when he gets angry as a pale
girl begins to sort of drift away you
end up having Jeff banister and company
who show up and then find Wolverine just
sitting there under the idea that he had
killed all the other x-men this is kind
of an interesting thing here the way
that Wolverine is sitting is the exact
way he was sitting during old man Logan
when he killed although all the x-men
and that story but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring all the
bring this video to an end I can't talk
if you are new here two comments explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]